et on continue à 7,8 week-end avec les
invités du vendredi messieurs bonjour
bonjour bonjour et d'appuyer vous êtes
animateur danse et musique au sein de
l'association cali bordel qui est une
association de guyancourt et votre
association propose un spectacle de
danse irlandaise samedi soir et qui
canent bonjour je m'en sortais un beau
papier tous les documents vous êtes
président de l'association lutte contre
la mucoviscidose à saint rémy les
chevreuse mais si vous êtes en plateau
avec nous aujourd'hui c'est que votre
association propose un spectacle de
danse aussi cette la guerre de la
devance ce week-end donc samedi soir à
l'espace jean racine à saint-émilion va
commencer par vous ennuyer parler de ce
spectacle de samedi soir alors c'est pas
tout à fait un spectacle en fait c'est
un bal malsain baba d'irlande là bas
l'irlande est donc
bon c'est de 20h à 23h30 c'est un bal
qui se situera donc maison de quartier
joseph kosma à guyancourt place jacques
brel
tout alors ces voix là c'est sûr tout
cela c'est que tout le monde même les
personnes qui ne savent pas danser sont
invités pourront danser avec nous ce
soir là ça veut dire quand même venu
qu'il faut pas savoir danser mais malgré
tout fort quand même quelques notions de
pas de danse irlandaise mais c'est pas
simple à danser en mauvaises non alors
disons que bon il faut bien voir qu'il
ya plusieurs types de danses irlandaises
nom fera pas des systèmes dancing qui
est en gros les claquettes irlandaises
on lira pas de ça mais par contre ce
sont des danses avec des souvent marché
où les pas de polka fin qui sont
relativement simples et à chaque fois
elles seront expliqués en une minute ou
deux et c'est parti si les premiers
retours de dons sont des fois très
hésitant tati tout se met en place au
bout de trois quatre tours et c'est très
bien tout le monde prend son plaisir
donc voilà c'est ouvert à tous et
possibilité à tous de danser sachant que
en dehors de cela il ya possibilité de
regarder d'écouter parce que là aussi
les spectacles et puis surtout ce ballet
précédé d'un stage
si jamais vraiment au nom qu'elle
connaît un peu les pas de danse j'ai
comme un stage après midi voilà les
apprécier mais voilà donc ceux qui
souhaitent peuvent venir au stage donc
de 14h à 17h30 environ pour apprendre
les danses
les pas de base et le les figures et
dédiant ce qu'on mettra en application
le soir même avec donc à quai de groupes
dont qui râlent les musiciennes caliber
donne donc et puis un groupe de paris
qui est spécialisé dans les danses
irlandaises qui s'appelle dont les
patients du docteur frank qui est très
réputée sur parier
je pense que comme non les patients dr
frank oui on voit ça pendant six ans vit
ça fait quoi et où la ces et médecine
oui en fait
leur les gens de sécher docteur franck y
avait un bar avec un verset de la ville
d'aboisso brune et
moyennant un peu de musique les patients
de ce docteur se trouvait
revigoré sans problème on va dire que
les boissons à consommer cloud et il ya
bien sûr ça donne de l'ardeur du coup on
doit savoir bien danser les panneaux
c'est un an des cantons a consommé la
fameuse voix le breuvage de couleur vous
d'accord donc ça c'est les ateliers
l'après-midi et donc le bal irlandais le
soir ces maisons de quartier joseph
kosma à guyancourt je m'attendais un we
can alors vous c'est samedi soir alors
samedi c'est de la danse pour la 9e
année c'est à dire que c'est une
une séance de danse qui est monté par
mon épouse au profit de vaincre la
mucoviscidose
où se produisent un certain nombre de
groupes du coin plus généralement une
vedette qui vient généreusement offrir
sa prestation et là c'est pas n'importe
qui non alors là c'est pas n'importe qui
nous avons deux vedettes mais
il ya déjà
une personne qui est proche de philippe
découflé je vais vous cherchez
mais ça sert à
cazaubon elle la danse et chez découflé
la produire 2 solo
là à
un prestigieux passé à le prix il ya
deux ans d'une demi heure dans ce sens
france etc en attend beaucoup de la
prestation elle est passée du reste nous
ne l'avons pas auditionner elle est
passée au théâtre de saint quentin il ya
un an et quelques mois et elle est
terriblement marqué par sa présence je
pense que quand on a travaillé aux côtés
de philippe découflé oui je crois que ça
va la carte de visite le nom suffit
mais il ya en plus beaucoup de groupes
qui sont là en particulier corps espace
danse qui est bien connu ici puisque
c'est l'école de monkey ni
mon rêve glickman était directrice il ya
quelques temps maintenant et vole de ses
propres ailes en particulier son fils
qui nous fera deux prestations avec
d'une part les jeunes du coin et puis un
groupe d'ados sont en pleine répétition
ce moment encore en pleine répétition
pour l édition pour demain soir pour la
mise en place tôt oui d'accord ok on est
rassuré centrales
et donc tout l'argent qui sera à
collecter ou alors il a collecté
intégralement mattel intégralement
intégralement à vaincre la mucoviscidose
un tic
simplement les boissons mais enfin c'est
nous qui fournissons la nourriture pour
autant qu'on puisse les bénévoles
même certains danseurs apporte également
c'est qu'il faut c'est notre principe de
base quand on organise quelque chose
sans que ça coûte le moins cher possible
et que tous puissent remonter à
dax est la même le même principe que
nous appliquons à la virade alliera de
l'espoir qui se passe cette année le
matin 9 septembre et c'est exactement la
même
raison votre engagement sincère
associations alors bon pour moi je ne
suis pas du tout touché par la maladie
il se trouve que
on connaissait la mucoviscidose sommes
un petit peu jeu deux minutes pour en
parler allez-y
génétique c'est madhi génétique la plus
importante en france il ya quand même
deux mille malades
c'est une maladie génétique qui est
resté cible je veux pas rentrer dans le
détail parce que je suis un peu chez un
scientifique donc
monsieur m'a dit récessif ça veut dire
que les deux parents à chaque fois
qu'ils ont un enfant ils ont une chance
sur quatre s'ils sont porteurs de la
maladie d'avoir un enfant malade et
cette maladie tu me lis terrible où
l'espérance de vie était de septembre il
ya un peu de
jouer bien c'est une moyenne de
27 ans l'âge avec ldc de l'ehpad avec
les contraintes médicales qui soignent
les calculs sont évidemment d'être
tout simplement il tend à la retraite je
me suis sentie fiq à la retraite je me
suis dit et je vais faire quelque chose
quand ces gens là et il se trouve que
j'en connais en plus donc manifestation
organisée au profit de la lutte contre
la mucoviscidose une question sur le
prix d'entrée de vos manifestations
n'ont alors
pas d'emploi et danser irlande et ans
irlandais mons et 8 euros pour les non
adhérents 3 0 pour les adhérents pour la
partie stage on demande des adhérents
c'est 5 euros pour être adhérent donc
quelqu'un qui voudra faire le stage et
le bal s'est lui fait aussi 8 euros
d'abord c'est pas bien cher non on ne
s'en passer une soirée de danse avec de
ce soit accessible à puteaux la plupart
autant
on a la même approche c'est à dire que
les places sont à 10 euros ou plus
puisque c'est qu'ici les gens veulent
ferrat dont personne ne l'en empêche et
c'est 6 euros pour les enfants de moins
de 12 ans d'accord donc à chaque fois
des prêts d'entrée qui sont ultra
accessible pour vos deux manifestations
respectives une dernière question sur le
rôle de l'association cali bordel qu'est
ce que vous proposez durant toute
l'année en dehors de ce bal votre
grandeur de ce ballon nous avons des
ateliers donc danses musiques et chants
traditionnel de france et d'ailleurs
donc
nous animons donc des mâles nous animons
également souvent nous avons un volet
social solidarité donc nous a fait taire
menons auprès des associations
caritatives pour soit animé de quelques
soirées pour au bénéfice des
bénéficiaires de ces associations soient
également des balkans et filmant pour
récolter de l'argent pour reverser à des
associations comme pour le téléthon
d'ailleurs entre autres et
éventuellement on fait aussi des
spectacles
à l'occasion voilà l occasion indique
alan meur de de ce spectacle familial
autres manifestations à lhassa ciani
fonction les salles disponibles ou des
églises disponible en l'occurrence on
organise un gospel dans l'année toujours
pareil au profit de vaincre la
mucoviscidose
que la compagnie de gospel l'arc en ciel
qui est basée à l'accueil en yvelines
les dates n'ont pas encore cette année
parce que tous des marchés l'appel est
lancé voilà non mais tu reviendrais
pouvoir s'y dit elle sans taux d'arrêts
auprès des églises parce
qu'effectivement c'est très joli un
concert de gospel ça serait bien qu'ils
ont déjà donné une dizaine de choix et
puis il ya également traditionnellement
dans le dernier week-end de septembre la
virade de l'espoir ou comme monsieur
nous avons une le samedi un fest-noz et
souvent il ya des répétitions dans le
samedi après midi pour que les gens
apprennent à danser breton voilà c'est
super c'est très complémentaire merci à
vous d'être venu sur ce plateau donc je
rappelle rapidement le bal irlandais à
la maison de quartier joseph kosma a eu
en course et samedi soir précédant un
stage de danse si jamais vous voulez
apprendre quelques pas de danse et puis
un spectacle de danse au profit de la
lutte contre la mucoviscidose samedi
soir l'espace jean racine à saint rémy
les chevreuse merci messieurs